we begin with breaking news in Ukraine
where Russian bombs have fallen on
cities far beyond the front lines
including the capital city of Kiev there
are multiple dead end wounded and the
numbers are still Rising this follows a
fiery explosion over the weekend that
took out a bridge in Crimea a crucial
link between Russia and the territory it
illegally annexed Charlie dagada is in
Ukraine for us Charlie good morning
good morning to you in a televised
address this morning President Vladimir
zielinski said Russia is trying to
destroy us and wipe us off the face of
the Earth and to spread panic and Chaos
it follows Nationwide missile strikes in
what's seen as direct retaliation for
the bombing of the Crimean bridge over
the weekend we should warn you this
report contains images some might find
disturbing
thunderous explosions shook the heart of
the Ukrainian Capital this morning right
in the middle of Rush Hour leaving
streets near the Central maidon Square
in Flames this was purely punitive meant
to strike Terror in densely populated
Urban neighborhoods close to government
buildings even hitting a children's
playground
a terrified young woman posting on
social media after the first strike
captured the ferocity of a second blast
but she appeared to have escaped Serious
injury
does it and a live BBC report
interrupted
by incoming missiles security camera
footage showed a strike beside a
pedestrian bridge near the arch of
Freedom the gloves came off in a
coordinated assault across at least 10
cities like dinipro far to the West in
leviv and again overnight in zapparesia
the frequent Target of Russian
bombardment that has left more than 60
civilians dead in the past 10 days alone
apparent payback for this the explosion
on the Crimean bridge over the weekend
that left oil tankers on the railway
line in flames and dropped a section of
the parallel Road into the sea Russian
intelligence Services blamed the blast
on a truck bomb saying it's the work of
Ukrainian special agents president
addressing the nation saying
there is no doubt this is an act of
terrorism aimed at destroying civilian
infrastructure and a psychological
attack on a hated symbol of Russia's
illegal annexation of Crimea ever since
Putin opened the bridge back in 2018
it's not only of strategic importance
Russia's only land bridge to the
peninsula making it harder to move
supplies it's a physical representation
of Putin's land grab of Ukrainian
territory with its cities in Flames this
morning Ukraine can only brace for
further blowback
in an emergency meeting with his
Security Council today Putin warned that
Russia's response to further attacks
would be severe and another worrying
development Belarus has announced a
joint military task force with Russia
that country is much closer to the
capital Kiev and was used as a launch
pad for Russian troops in the initial
Invasion Gail
thank you Charlie Daggett a reporting
from Ukraine